we're going to begin this hour with a
look at the steady rise in long-term
coronavirus cases in this country it is
estimated nearly one in five americans
who have been infected have so-called
long-coveted that is when symptoms last
three months or longer dr john lapook
reported on research to diagnose and
treat long covet and the struggles
patients face he did that for cbs sunday
morning take a look
it's very isolating
you feel like you're disconnected to the
world
the world is moving on without you and
you're you kind of feel
invisible that's a terrible feeling it
is
ken todd works for cbs's parent company
paramount global but we met him through
survivor corps a long coveted patient
support organization todd used to be a
crossfit fanatic but a month after
contracting covid he found even a stroll
in the park would exhaust him were you
short of breath at all i was not short
of breath no chest pains nope just a
weird feeling
i went home and i slept
for probably a couple of hours and then
felt better but that was really the
beginning
of realizing that
something different is going on here
what's been going on are the unresolved
and to outside appearances largely
invisible consequences of covid19
for ken todd that means fatigue
dizziness inability to regulate his body
temperature and difficulty concentrating
those are among the most typical
symptoms though chest pain palpitations
and shortness of breath are also
commonly reported
can you diagnose long covet on a blood
test no x-ray no cat scan no mri no
brain scan no physical exam
no so you can imagine how that would be
disconcerting to somebody who has some
symptoms yes indeed the scientific
community needs to quickly understand
what's going on it needs to quickly make
some criteria some diagnostic rules
here at nyu langone health where i'm a
professor of medicine dr leora horowitz
has gone from treating patients during
the worst of the pandemic to searching
for a way to diagnose and treat long
covid
dr horwitz is helping to guide a one
billion dollar study run by the national
institutes of health it's called recover
and its goal is to learn why so many
people who contract covid19 are
reporting long-term symptoms i've been
in research for 25 years i have never
seen a study of this scale and this
scope will start in such a short amount
of time
and dr john lapook joins us now john
good morning good to see you so what did
you learn about the nih study and the
time frame to get some answers yeah
they're ramping up pretty quickly they
got about a third of the way there in
terms of adults getting to about
eighteen thousand uh they're a third of
the way there but dr horowitz you just
saw said that we can help the study
because there's underrepresentation in
certain communities uh people who are
hispanic come from rural communities who
are currently infected never infected or
were pregnant during covet and they want
children of all ages no matter what
their covent status is so it's something
that we can do to help this uh this
study go along you go to
recoverkovid.org
you can sign up oh that would be great
dr lapook you know we're in this new
wave you know the power
whatever number it is of code but i know
multiple people we all do that have
coped right now are people less likely
to get long coveted if they're getting
covered right now because maybe they
might be vaccinated or we're better able
to treat it yeah that's one of the
things we're trying to tease out there
trying to tease out it does turn out
that if you were vaccinated you do lower
the risk of getting long covet but these
kind of questions about what are the
risks and who who are the populations
who get it and what to do about it these
are all things that we're trying to
figure out with these long terms if you
suffer from long covid you you test
negative if given a pcr test correct but
you have symptoms that are not explained
any other way right so how do you
diagnose it you went through that list
and it seemed like it is so frustrating
for people because they feel lousy and
and some people really are debilitated
uh but there's no specific blood test
there's no brain scan there's no cat
scan there's there's nothing on physical
exam that specifically says you have
long covet and that's one of the things
they're trying to look for biomarkers
maybe do some sort of blood test that
can figure it out or even cerebral
spinal fluid uh but there are all these
theories about why people have it i mean
there are four ones that we mentioned in
the pieces how do they how do they then
screen people for this big study then to
make sure that the self-identified
long-covered sufferers yeah there are
symptoms i mean there there are dozens
and dozens and one one person said oh
there are like 200 symptoms and how are
you supposed to figure it out and how
are you supposed to treat it and how you
have a symptom but you lost your sense
of taste for example or you're out of
breath when you go for a walk how do you
treat that yeah so two questions one is
how do you diagnose it and how do you
recruit people and one of the things is
you know people know they're just
feeling lousy uh you know more than a
month after and they come in and they
say let's try to tease this out maybe
it's something else maybe it is this in
terms of treatment uh two of the
theories are that um
you your immune system is overactive so
the virus is gone right but your body
doesn't realize it's gone or maybe your
body is mistaking there's something
similar between the virus and something
that's part of your own body it's
attacking it yourself it's like an
autoimmune thing so maybe you could do
something to try to decrease the immune
response the other thing that i think is
fascinating is there is evidence there
is that there are remnants of the virus
in some people uh it can be found shed
in stool months
after the virus is you know suppose
supposedly you're over the initial
episode of covid so that's fascinating
uh that's in a certain subpopulation of
people but if that's true then maybe
giving something like paxlovit or
another antiviral to try to flush it out
later could be something none of that
has been tried yet these are all
theories they're going to have to do a
lot of trials to see okay how do we
identify it how do we say
which is the subpopulation of people uh
who get this treatment or that treatment
it's not going to be one size fits all
it's i'm sure it's going to be different
types of it's not going to be one report
if it's all either i'm sure you'll be
back on this you'll ask me back
thank you
john dr john lapook thank you very much